N
EMPTY.
JUST LIKE ALL THOSE GAS BOMBS
ACROSS THE NATION.
HERE NOW, FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND AMERICA
FIRST LEGAL FOUNDER
STEPHEN MILLER STEPHEN MILLER.
WELL, SO FIRST, STEPHEN, NO
INFLATION, THEN IT IS JUST
TEMPORARY, AND THAT IT IS A
HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM, AND NOW
INFLATION IS A GOOD THING.
YOUR RESPONSE?
>> SO, WE ARE TRULY LIVING IN
ONE OF THE MOST ASTONISHING
MOMENTS IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF
SAID THAT RUNAWAY INFLATION AND
CRIPPLED SUPPLY CHAINS ARE A
HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM.
A HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM IS WHEN
RON KLAIN SHOWS UP LATE FOR
DINNER AND THEY RUN OUT OF
TRUFFLES.
THAT IS A HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM.
AND I'M SURE RON IS FAMILIAR
WITH THAT EXPERIENCE.
IT IS NOT A HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM
IF YOU CAN'T PAY YOUR GROCERY
BILL AND YOU ARE HUNGRY, OR YOU
CAN'T PAY YOUR HEATING BILL AND
YOU ARE COLD, OR YOUR KIDS
CHRISTMAS PRESENTS WON'T ARRIVE
UNTIL EASTER.
THOSE ARE WORKING-CLASS
PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE CAUSING SUFFERING
TODAY.
AND TO ME, THIS UNDERSCORES THE
POINT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ALWAYS MADE SO WELL, WHICH IS
THAT THE ELITES AREN'T ELITE IN
THE LITERAL SENSE OF THE TERM,
AS IN SMART AND INTELLIGENT AND
CAPABLE.
THIS SHOWS PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PRIVILEGE AND TO HAVE POWER AND
WHO HAVE POSITION HAVE NO
EARTHLY CLUE WHAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY DOING, AND THAT IS ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT WAS SO SUCCESSFUL,
BECAUSE HE KEPT HIS EYE ON THE
BALL OF WORKING-CLASS ISSUES:
WAGES, 401(K)s, JOBS, TRADE,
THE THINGS THAT ACTUALLY
AFFECTED REGULAR, WORKING
FAMILIES.
NOW THIS ADMINISTRATION, THEY
ARE THINKING ABOUT THE
$3.5 TRILLION DEAL, AND HOW MANY
PLUG IN CAR INSTALLATIONS THEY
CAN AFFORD.
THEY ARE TOTALLY OUT OF TOUCH
WITH WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
COUNTRY, AND THE ONLY REASON
THEY ARE ADDRESSING IT NOW IS
BECAUSE THE MEDIA SAID HEY,
GUYS, YOU MIGHT WANT TO TACKLE
THIS BEFORE YOU GET SHELLACKED
EVEN HARDER IN THE MIDTERMS.
>> THERE IS A TERM WE USE IN
POLITICS, WHEN WE SAY WE EITHER
HAVE AN OPTICS PROBLEM OR WE
HAVE A REALITY PROBLEM, AN
OPTICS PROBLEM IF SOMETHING
ISN'T ACTUALLY BAD BUT IT IS
MADE TO LOOK THAT WAY.
A REALITY PROBLEM IS WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS, AND EVEN THE
EXTRAORDINARY MESSAGING SKILLS
OF RON KLAIN AREN'T ENOUGH TO
GET OUT OF THE REALITY PROBLEM.
THE REALITY PROBLEM IS AN
INFLATION CRISIS, ENERGY CRISIS,
JOBS CRISIS, AFGHANISTAN CRISIS,
COVID CRISIS, AND A SOUTHERN
BORDER CRISIS, AND NOW A SUPPLY
CHAIN CRISIS.
YOU CAN'T TALK YOUR WAY OUT OF
IT.
YOU EITHER FIX THE PROBLEMS OR
YOU DON'T.
AND THIS SHOWS -- FLIP IT,
ENDORSEMENT RON KLAIN HAS MADE
ABOUT HIGH-CLASS NONSENSE,
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO SOLVE
THESE PROBLEMS BUT ARE MAKING
THEM WORSE.
THE RECONCILIATION BILL MEANS
MORE INFLATION.
THEY ARE GUTTING I.C.E., MEANS
MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
AND JOE BIDEN HAS NO IDEA
WHATSOEVER WHAT HE IS GOING TO
DO ABOUT THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CRISIS, WHICH MEANS THE
ESSENTIAL THINGS THAT YOU NEED
FOR YOUR FAMILY AREN'T GOING TO
SHOW UP UNTIL IT IS TOO LATE TO.
>> Jesse: YEAH, HE IS GOING TO
RUIN CHRISTMAS, AND THAT IS
PRETTY MUCH CLEAR, YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO FLY ANYWHERE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE PROTESTING
THE MANDATES, AND THERE IS GOING
TO BE NO PRESENTS UNDER THE
TREE, MAYBE IN JANUARY THEY'RE
GOING TO GET THERE, BUT IT IS
INTERESTING WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
THE REALITY CRISIS.
THEY TRIED TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS
ON THE BORDER, WHICH REALLY WAS
A REAL CRISIS, THAT WAS REALITY,
BY HIDING THE KIDS.
REMEMBER, THEY WOULDN'T LET THE
MEDIA AND THE POLITICIANS IN
CAGES.
THEN THEY JUST MOVE THE KIDS
SOMEWHERE ELSE, AND THAT JUST
MADE IT GO AWAY.
THEN FOX FLIES THE DRONE
OVERHEAD AND YOU CAN ACTUALLY
SEE ALL THE HAITIANS -- IT IS
ALL ABOUT HIDING AND DEFLECTING.
OH, THE BORDER IS FINE, WE'VE
GOT IT UNDER CONTROL, JUST DON'T
LOOK.
YOU CAN DO THAT WITH INFLATION.
>> THEIR RESPONSE WAS OH, MY
GOD, WE HAVE THE WORLDS LARGEST
MIGRANT CAMP ILLEGALLY IN THE
WHOLE HISTORY OF CIVILIZATION,
GET THAT DRONE OUT OF THE SKY,
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO FIND AND
ARREST BILL MELUGIN.
THAT IS LITERALLY THEIR STRATEGY
FOR THE BORDER CRISIS BECAUSE
THE REALITY IS, THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT WORKING PEOPLE.
AND THIS IS THE POINT I REALLY
WANT TO MAKE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT WORKING
PEOPLE.
THEY WANT POWER AND PRIVILEGE
FOR THEMSELVES, AND THAT IS
ULTIMATELY WHAT CAME ACROSS IN
THAT HORRENDOUS POST FROM THE
CHIEF OF STAFF.
>> Jesse: YEAH, YOU CAN'T HIDE
PRICE INCREASES FROM THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT